shutterstock chose your boy Puff Daddy
representing that bad boy coop and I'm
teamed up with my family over at the WWE
and my people already 2k to curate the
dopest soundtrack for 2k 17-game our
audience is one of the most diverse
audiences in the world and your WWE
audience kind of matches up with that
you know you know WWE or this is very
diverse so you have to give people you
know what they want you know and also
what they need so we hit on with some
raw you know some pop even and I with
some classics and even handle with some
electronica but the WWE new to come get
the best which is me the team up with
them and you know even some artists
called me up once they found out I was a
product this is a very prestigious thing
and so you know French Montana one of
the artists on the label um he said you
know don't leave me out of this one is
one is big like I grew up with that WWE
we've all grown up with W
putting together this soundtrack is a
very collaborative effort this is not my
first rodeo with the WWE we did the
tribute to the troops I'm not done
WrestleMania with them may even
supported some of my new talent MGK and
also when i launched my network or vote
we're like one big family that kind of
brings our talents together from the
world of music and the world of
wrestling and just understanding how to
build brands and we do things together
we trust in each others like taste level
and decisions and so it's always a
pleasure always learn something when I
work with these guys over there
my favorite track on to k-17 is larger
our French Montana so one of my hidden
gems is run by bringing her ride that's
a mean one and then when you're ready to
get out of control you gotta listen to
out of control by travis walker it gets
crazy another hidden gem that would be
hard you know able to to like reach some
nature I would love to see that one
let's make that happen
you